all right charles charles
where'd you grow up where you from
originally columbus ohio philadelphia
where columbus ohio moved to
philadelphia oh columbus and philly
um tell me about your childhood how was
my childhood i was in group homes
uh my uncle was abusive um
my father was passed away my mother died
when i was 13.
so who raised you mostly raised me i was
in silver springs
up in you know up in concha hockey
outside of philadelphia yeah your mom at
least your mom and dad
she passed away yeah and then you went
to foster system yes
how was the foster system for you it was
it was kind of combination many things
it was kind of rough at first
you know some days you had your highs
and lows they kept you they kept you on
medication a lot
you know melarel things like that
for what kind of for emotionally
disturbed all kinds of stuff
you know and uh i wasn't bipolar but uh
paranoid schizophrenic hmm so mental
mental issues have been
going yeah basically not that i'm crazy
it's just it
yeah you go through a lot of changes
right
and uh what uh where did you like go
after the foster system what did i like
about the foster ceo
where did your life go after the foster
system after the foster system i
i went to live with this lady mrs
blackwell she came and took me like as a
house parent
you know and i stayed for four years
then i went to um then i went to reading
pennsylvania
reading pets from writing pennsylvania
i um became homeless
got off the street became homeless again
it was a reoccurring thing about four
times
and got off the street now we're
homeless again
at this car then drugs have been a part
of your life
pardon me how how long have drugs been a
part of your life um
i don't really do drugs hardcore i do
marijuana oh is that right but i'm
really obsessed with it
it's like an obsession but i don't see
it as no worse than any other drug you
know if you're obsessed with it
i'm very compulsive about it
how much pot do you smoke a day i would
smoke maybe
two to three packages a day
i would smoke one joint every 15 minutes
is that right throughout the day yes sir
i couldn't sell any drugs
i couldn't sell marijuana because i
couldn't keep it long enough
because you were smoking it yes
constantly
[Music]
i'm a cigarette abuser or a marijuana
abuser you still smoking today
yes you discovered potter what age
i was i was 13. 13.
i stopped for like three years and then
started again
three years you stopped how did your
life change how did that life change
oh maybe you stopped when you were not
smoking when i wasn't smoking
things were a little better but they
weren't perfect
you know you think you're addicted to it
yes i would say i was addicted to it i
mean i don't know that past addictive
it is it could be addictive yes it can i
could be addictive
because i've been smoking for quite a
while but smoke for 18 years
like i said off and on yeah and where
are you staying now
where am i staying at over on the other
side of the bridge of cardboard
you just you just sleep on the street
yeah i come on the bus
and i come down and get food and my
current address is a cardboard up
on the other side of the highway so
you're living on a piece of cardboard
basically you could say
yeah and i get clothes at the shelters
and stuff
what keeps you from working what keeps
people working and getting a job
my doctor i could work i have an injured
neck
right but i could work but i can't
really hold the steady job as of yet
the doctor told me that i would have to
get their permission before i could do
that
you know how do you know how old am i
55. 55. do you have kids no i have no
children
you ever been in love have you ever been
in love have i ever been in love
three times struck out twice the other
one
was kind of my fault
actually it was both of our faults that
take the bit
yeah i haven't seen this i haven't seen
her since
looking back at your life what what do
you think might have
i wish things would have been different
what do you think what do you wish was
different
i wish my attitude to things would have
been different i wish i would have
learned more than i do now
i wish i if i had it to do all over
again i wouldn't have done it that way
well done what way the things that i did
you know the abuse of pie oh i see the
abuse of cigarettes
so if you want to tell young people it's
not a it's not a game
that's interesting because today the
attitude with pot is that it's
it's medicinal and it's yeah it's not
exactly dangerous
it's not exactly dangerous but it
because it could become habit for me
how do you think pot affects your
behavior what it does is it makes you
hungry
that it does i'm not so sure it depends
on a person probably makes them horny
some people don't you know some people
it relaxes them some people
yeah they're strong there's different
kinds of pot right yes yeah
you know people react differently to it
it depends on what kind you're smoking
yes but the key is not to get hooked
like i did
because you'll wish you didn't
and stopping is not uh i i could stop
it's difficult
it's very difficult just like in any
other drug
you know but you don't see people having
the same problems with crap
with pot as they do like with crack or
with heroin things like that well ca
like i said from from my perspective
from being down here
being around people it depends on what
their problems are
you know it depends on how affected they
were do you think it exacerbates your
mental issues
do you think it it heightens your mental
problems um it can
but you mentioned earlier you have some
like you can it can affect it
it can't affect it to a certain extent
in most cases not at all you know
like i said it varies dear friends do i
have friends
i have three friends one is not in town
right now
where do you see your life going now
well we could go either way it could
either go down here or go up
so it's basically neutral i'm hoping for
the best
you know i would prefer to go uphill
yeah
have you seen doctors for your mental
issues yes
and what are they i see two of them oh
you still you still do yeah i still see
them but i have to go way out to the
valley in order to see one yeah are you
taking meds for
yeah i'm taking uh i'm taking aldo right
now i'm sorry i apologize i'm taking
um a bella five for schizophrenia yeah
yeah and what what does your
schizophrenia
manifest in your life as what does it
make you do
okay i'll be honest with you it's
paranoid schizophrenia right
but there are times where i'm telling
the truth about stuff and people won't
believe it
you know so they just chalk it off to be
that it's because of this
paranoid schizophrenia but it's not
always the case
so schizophrenia seems to
look very different in different people
yes
some more heightened than others
depending on and plus when you're
exposed to different things too
yeah to create different problems other
than just that
and when did that when did schizophrenia
kind of take hold in your life
in your 20s when did it take hold should
it took hold when i was um
i didn't start register i was like 22.
yeah that's usually the age where it
kind of
shows up but at first i was in denial of
it you know
the doctor told me that schizophrenia i
told a man you don't know what you're
talking about
[Music]
but i didn't realize i actually did have
it
until i started showing signs of it
then i started feeling guilty depressed
nine yards
and is is the pot kind of a way of
treating it
for you i think it's both i think it's
recreational and a treatment
for me i can't speak for others yeah and
your pot use has
increased or decreased or stayed steady
has it decreased
it's smoking power has it
it has it's changed
but there was a time to where i was just
smoking it every five minutes
and there was a part of me saying slow
down slow down but the other part of me
wouldn't listen to it
so you're literally literally smoking a
joint every 15 minutes yes
and that's no lie that's a lot of
smoking
yeah and i said to myself i might be out
of control
i've had people tell me you know man you
smoke too much pot man
and there's some people say man go ahead
it's okay just go ahead and smoke as
much pot as you want
i mean would you say you were high or
you were just
oh i'd be high are you when's the last
time you smoked today when was the last
time i smoked today
actually i haven't had any in four days
well you haven't smoked
but i've said there was a current time i
was from the four day period i was
smoking heavy
when i actually was smoking i mean you
couldn't tell me to put it down you know
yeah so right right now you're not high
no yeah
no i'm not but you but you'll probably
smoke later today or
uh you want honesty that's a big
question mark
i might i might not and what what will
it
decide whether you do or don't what
would decide
yeah i mean something stressful or just
nothing to do or
whether you have money most likely
nothing to do so
if there's nothing to do you'll get high
and yeah and just
zone out well just get high and just say
how the hell would it just let everybody
do what they do
you know i mean retreat my my business
you know don't come get me to help you
do nothing i just want to
be left alone that's your way of
checking out well i wouldn't say copying
out but maybe
checking out i mean just kind of just
like
not being involved in other people's
lives or your own life even yes
that um that scares me sometimes
what are the what are the benefits the
benefits i don't get in a lot of trouble
you what i don't get in a lot of trouble
with the benefits
but the lack the lack of it for me is
that
that i'd be regretting not being
involved in something i should have been
involved in and then i wind up missing
out yeah does it affect your drive or
your focus
yes it can yeah yeah you know that'll
keep your life from going anywhere right
yeah and it becomes like a lit it
becomes a sort of like a
like you thought it was great and also
it's a letdown yeah
you've had jobs in your life i've had
three
what kind of highest paid job was a
security company called general security
i was making ten dollars an hour
and um i won't even get into how i lost
that job
it's too embarrassing i really don't
want you know
i don't really want the public to know
how i went about that
what does it have to do with department
what does it have to do with
let's just say i was supposed to fill in
for somebody
or actually what happened was i was
stationed somewhere
and i was promised to be put back in my
other station
but what happened was they reneged on me
on it and i made a fuss about it and
they said
you go back there or you're fired but i
quit before they could fire me
so i was caught between a rock and r
place basically
but i won't get into the details of how
that happened me cussing out my superior
stuff like that you know what i mean had
this big argument in the office
no getting fired is no [ __ ] big
shouting match
yeah i can imagine yeah
anyway that's what happened and living
on the street you do you
do you see yourself getting i don't see
myself dying but i don't i don't see
myself
uh i'm not gonna sit there and say that
being on the street is like the
greatest thing in the world no some
people believe it's the greatest thing
in the world
depends on the person's point of view
but me i don't think being on the street
or jail are the greatest things in the
world right you've been in jail too
yeah and i don't in the first day i went
i i wanted to get out the very first day
i got there
but we got you in jail huh
steve receiving stolen property um
nine times you know uh things like that
so you've been in jail a few times
yeah you could say that misdemeanors
yeah how does living on the street
or how does how does this lifestyle that
you're living when you're off stream
emotionally okay when you're on the
street you feel like you got nowhere to
go
you do have places to go but you're so
depressed you think you don't have
nowhere to go
you see what i'm saying yeah but then
you have to confront the problem of
how where do you go and how do you get
there
and plus you have to deal with all the
other baggage too it could be
frightening
and if you just smoke then you don't
want to even look at it but you still
have to come back to the same basic
problem you know eventually yeah but
yeah not if you're smoking every 15
minutes let's see that's the yeah but
that's the depression i still smoke to
get rid of the pain yeah there's always
mental illness behind all these
yes behaviors i think but here's the
weird thing when i smoke to get rid of
it it comes right back again after you
get the high comes down
and it's like you can't it's like a
vicious how long does the height last
how long is a high elastic and lasting
we're up to maybe
five to six hours something like
depending on the type quality you smoke
and no matter what kind of drug you
smoke
basically i'm only speaking for myself
now
it's not going to make the the actual
reality of her situation go away
and you've been smoking pot for decades
has has the quality
improved or some of it is approved but
lately people have been selling some of
the bogus stuff and keeping the good
stuff for themselves and that's what's
making me mad and frustrated i might
want to quit
all together because it's because you're
not getting the quality that you'd like
yes and since they legalized it recently
it wouldn't make a difference
they're still not giving the quality you
like and it's starting to make me feel
like well what the hell am i smoking it
for
if i can't get the quality i'm looking
for you know
have you tried any of the harder drugs
no never i tried blow once but blow
didn't do anything for me
it didn't do anything so i wasn't
interested in it
if it's something i'm not interested in
i'm not going to do it
i don't care who's got it you know
if you have something i'm not interested
i'm not going to do it i don't care of
you or whoever else has it
yeah that's just how i operate what do
you say the most important lesson you've
learned in your life is
is that i made a big mistake when i
started smoking pot obsessively
i want to get back to praying something
i
made the biggest mistake of my life for
not doing that's one of the biggest
mistakes i ever made
all right charles well thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck hope you get
off the street
i do too all right thank you